that's a tick children who enjoyed this  to wake are 43 percent more likely to  eat their veggies every search shows  that children to enjoy this toy are 43  percent more likely to eat a dick  [Music]  I want to hear what Childers saying  but without the show  [Music]  I can't reach them  [Music]  to give Jeff that kind of unfettered  reach its ludicrously unsafe  oh good but unlimited that's an economy  cable divinsky bad tracheotomy angry god  on I'm angry and Joshi was driving the  cards her fall we lost Phil spit it out  [ __ ]  [Music]  years  show is a trap you're a terrible mother  [Music]  there was a special boy with an  imagination I fought to protect  [Music]  don't do drugs  [Music]  you  you  you